- [Mark] No, I...
The China one, yeah I know
she's got other problems
but with that video when,
people get really upset about it
especially when they find
out she was 13 and all that.
- Yeah but that's real shit though.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Real shit.
- [Mark] So what goes on in our world?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Look how great you look.
- Thank you.
I came.. I got ready and I was like,
I'm gonna really show up today.
- [Mark] Yeah, you did it right.
No, you're a smart girl.
- [Royalty] Thank you.
- [Mark] You're one of the
few I would say is really like
when you told me-
- [Royalty] Yeah, I'm a professional
- [Mark] When you told
me you're making money
it's like, of course you are
cause you're smarter than the rest.
(both laugh)
- Yeah, I mean...
I'm not going to say
that drug addicts are just stupid people
but it's just a lot of these girls.
They don't have goals like
before they were prostitutes
they genuinely didn't have goals.
They genuinely were just like settlers
and I've just never been that
type of person by nature.
You know like...like I
said in my last video
I wanted to be top notch things
like I didn't want to be a
mediocre person in society.
- [Mark] Yeah, mediocre
bores the hell out of me.
(Royalty laughs)
The only thing that interests
me is something extraordinary.
- Yeah, exactly
- [Mark] So maybe you and
I are similar that way.
And it's -
- Yeah
- [Mark] Anything other than great is-
- Yeah, if you're going to do something,
do it right and do it-
- [Mark] Even if it's
something like prostitution?
- Yeah, do it in a great way-
So-
- in the best you can be
- [Mark] You were telling me off camera
that now you're working
other areas other than-
- Yes, other than the streets
I've been starting to work the casinos.
And I really have been learning
the power of conversation
and how you just receive a lot more money
through conversation than sex
in a like an outrageous way.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And I just feel like every
prostitute should learn this
and get to that level because
the streets is depressing
and it can just really bring you down
like mentally, emotionally,
just in a whole bunch of ways.
But if you ever just
like dab into the casinos
and then you just like really start to see
that you're just worth so much more
than what you're used to.
- [Mark] So in the casinos,
these are in Las Vegas.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You'll encounter
an older man I assume
who likes the company of
a beautiful young girl
- Yeah
- [Mark] And you guys will
strike up a conversation
- Yeah, and it's not sexually related.
It's just-
- [Mark] He just loves
having your company.
- Yeah, it's just company.
It's conversation.
And it's like, you're
a beautiful young girl.
Why would he not want-
- [Mark] He wants to
treat you like a lady?
- A lot of these guys, they want to like
feel like they have a girlfriend
and a lot of girls that are
prostitutes, they'll be like,
oh, I don't do GFE and I don't do that.
And I don't either.
I don't do the bare back
or none of that weird shit
but GFE isn't necessarily that weird shit.
It's just, it's like
sugar baby type of thing.
- [Mark] For those who don't GFE is?
- Is a fantasy
- [Mark] It's a-
Its a salient fantasy
- [Mark] GFE stands for what girl-
- Girlfriend experience.
And like girls...they like translate
that into like bare back and like kissing
and all types of like weird shit
that you shouldn't do with the trick
and that's not necessarily what it is.
- [Mark] What I thought it would mean is
just like you're more
like you're interacting
as a boyfriend, girlfriend,
- Right
- [Mark] You're having conversations.
You're talking about movies
you're doing whatever you're doing.
- Right, and that's more compensation
for the girl in the long run.
- [Mark] Without getting naked?
- Right, because I mean, a man...
The woman who has his interests
like genuinely is always
going to be more interesting
than the girl that he
just got in the offline
that works with anybody.
- [Mark] Yeah, you lose
respect right away.
So you're making money?
- Yes.
- [Mark] You're one of the very few
- No, we all make money.
It's just what you do with your money.
- [Mark] Yeah, I guess that's it.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What are most of the
girls doing with their money?
- I mean, smoking, smoking some weed
getting that little X pills,
getting a little alcohol
getting a little outfits, normal stuff
because when you're on the streets
and you just see fugue
and like track shit,
you're just... it's like
a never ending cycle.
And if you never see anything,
that's like higher class or
the finer things in life,
you just think like,
oh, I'll go out here and make it again.
You know, it's a lifestyle and shit
but that shit really isn't a lifestyle.
It's just a trap.
- [Mark] And you've learned this
through your own investigation
or somebody turned you on?
- Yeah, like through my own investigation.
- [Mark] You're a very
resourceful young lady.
- Yeah, I mean-
- [Mark] As you explained last time
- I've always felt like
I was a special person.
Not even like on no cocky shit honestly
because I remember when
I first moved to LA,
I was 17 and I was walking
down Hollywood Boulevard.
And this producer, they were
like recording something
and he was telling me, he was
like, you're so beautiful.
And I was like, Oh My God,
like he's a whole Hollywood producer.
And he's telling me I'm beautiful.
And that's always stuck with me.
And I felt like I could do
anything I want with my beauty.
I have the power to take over the world.
- [Mark] You do.
That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's what it takes
to thrive in life, isn't it?
- Yeah.
It's more like confidence
within than on the outside.
- [Mark] But, what I've seen
is with all the people I interview.
So many of them, when an opportunity
to really get their lives
straight or get ahead
or make a lot of money
or do some job opportunity or anything.
They'll sabotage it.
- Yeah
- [Mark] They won't be able to accept it.
They'll flake on it.
They'll resist it somehow.
They'll do something to ruin it.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And do you think
like let's say Prince charming
came along in one of the casinos you're at
and said, "Hey! I just"...
he really likes you.
And what if you really liked him?
And all of a sudden, you guys like click
and he's wealthy and wants
you to stop doing this
would you actually go along with that?
Or do you think-
- Well, that...
I honestly feel like I
would never marry somebody
that I clearly have the
intentions to extort.
(Mark laughs)
But...
( she laughs)
- [Mark] Good for you
- But I would definitely have
a very close relationship with them.
Maybe figure out a angle that
we could both come out of
but I'm just too much of a
genuine person to do that.
- [Mark] Good for you.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you actually...
do you want to fall in love
and have kids one day and get out of-
- Of course I was watching
like the little other-
- [Mark] You're 18, so-
- Yeah, I was watching the other interview
with the pimp and the whore together
with a little trio thing.
They were nice, but she were like
you can't make a whore into a housewife.
And I was like, totally relate with...
I have a stuttering problem.
I was relating to what she was saying
when she was like I could be a housewife
to this certain person and
yeah, that's how I feel
- [Mark] That's the right person?
She's a dream girl for the right guy.
- She is, everyone is.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's what
makes the world go around.
- Yeah.
(she laughs)
- [Mark] I think is.
Yeah, everybody has a somebody.
- [Mark] So are you still in love?
- Sure.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] So do you... last
time you didn't answer.
Do you have a pimp?
- [Royalty] I mean,
I prefer not... I kind of
like to keep that personal.
- [Mark] Okay.
Well I won't... second
time I'll stop asking.
- [Royalty] Okay
- [Mark] What is your
definition of a pimp?
Because there's so many
different styles of these guys
- [Royalty] It's a man
who comes into a lady of the night's life
and he makes her better simply.
- [Mark] But there's
many different styles.
There's the guys who are-
- [Royalty] No, there's no style.
If you don't make her better
then you're not a pimp period.
- [Mark] So, what do you call these guys
that are like just street
thugs that are just-
- [Royalty] Whore hustlers.
- [Mark] What do you call them?
- [Mark] Oh, that's such a great term.
- [Royalty] Thank you.
(both laugh)
- [Mark] That's a great term.
I think I'll use that from now on,
because it's not right to call
all these tenancy pimps pimps.
- [Royalty] It's not
- [Mark] Cause they're so different.
The reason I use that term
is cause they're doing the same thing.
They're taking advantage of
women that do this for work
and they're keeping their money in there.
- [Royalty] They are not
here for the lifestyle.
It's all a hustle in their eyes.
- [Mark] Whore hustlers.
That's great.
- Exactly
- [Mark] So how much money
will you make in a casino
as opposed to like on the streets?
The street you'll make what?
- [Royalty] Like seven, eight
- [Mark] And in the
casino you'll make what?
- [Royalty] Like 18.
You can have the possibility
to make like two grands.
- [Mark] That's great.
Yeah.
- [Mark] I see why you're doing it.
- I just started Vegas,
so I'm still getting into swings.
I'm supposed to go like next week
and then I'm gonna go to Miami.
I never been to Miami
before, so that'll be a trip.
Sure.
- [Mark] And what about drugs?
- Drugs.
You know drugs, I've
been...I am an addict myself.
I've been struggling with
it for about a year now.
I started to like party with
my tricks for like more money
because they will pay you more money.
And I just got addicted.
I got addicted to drugs
and it has been a major
problem in my life,
but it's an everyday struggle.
I will be honest.
It's like, I wake up every day
and I'm like I'm not
going to get high today.
I'm just not going to do it
because I met a girl about two weeks ago
and she was like...I was
like do you want to ride?
And I gave her a ride and she was like
I'm on my way to this program.
And I was like, okay, what's the program?
And she's like, it's a rehab.
I've been smoking crystal for 22 years.
And I was just looking
at her and I could tell
that she was really beautiful
at a certain point in time.
And the way that she was talking
just reminding me of
myself in a lot of ways.
And I was just telling myself,
I was like you just need to stop.
Like, don't do any relapses
or nothing that can sabotage your future
because it's just... it's
a never ending cycle.
It's like really hell being
addicted to something.
I've seen a lot, I've come into
contact with a lot of signs.
I feel like that they're just telling me
to stop doing drugs.
- [Mark] Yeah, it can ruin your life.
- It can ruin your life.
And it's like relapses,
you tell yourself like, oh,
I'm just gonna you know,
no and it's hard for me because I do it.
And then I have to like,
literally go into my life
and I had to act normal
around the people that I love.
It's not like I have a binge
and I go off for days like no
I get high and I have to go back home
with the people that I love
and care about and act normal.
So it's really hard for me.
So I just decided to just say fuck it.
And to just, you know,
just think about those people
that I came into contact with.
Cause I don't wanna be that.
- [Mark] How many of the tricks
and how many of the girls
that do this kind of work
you think are addicted or using heavily?
- I feel like a lot of
girls definitely get high.
I mean, I wouldn't say
that they use like is
hard drugs is like crystal
but they definitely do like X
pills and all of that fuckery.
It's hard to stay sober
when you're a prostitute.
I understand that.
But I would strongly encourage
all the girls to just stop.
Smoke weed or whatever
but all the other stuff
that you say makes you
more looser to work,
it's just, it's not good
for you in the long run
because your body is depending on that.
- [Mark] Do you find you
get depressed doing this?
- No.
- [Mark] I asked you that
last time you said no.
- Yeah, I mean-
- [Mark] I can't imagine you wouldn't
like I would be depressed
for the first time.
- Yeah, it's not depressing.
It's not depressing
if you feel like you you're
working for something.
Yeah.
- [Mark] And would it be possible for you
to have a relationship with a man,
a real, a love relationship with somebody
while you're doing this on the side?
- No, I don't think so.
- [Mark] I don't either.
- I don't think so because I,
even when I was like a normal girl
I had a boyfriend and
stuff and we were poor.
We were like really poor.
Like I was sleeping in his car with him.
I was a minor and we were really poor.
Like I would count quarter
and think that I was balling
if I had like $5 in quarters,
like I was very poor
but I always had a
little bit of sex appeal.
So I would get what I wanted from men.
I would be like,
I'm hungry or this, this and that.
And it would just be
little acts of prostitution
here and there, but like I
wouldn't fuck them or anything.
But when I think about it now,
it's a little bit, it's
a dab, a prostitution
and he would get mad at me
and he would be like you're a slut
and you're a whore and
this, this and that.
- [Mark] Because you're flirting
with guys for a little bit-
- Yeah, because am flirting to
get what I want out of them.
And I just feel like I'll always do that.
I'm always gonna do that.
- [Mark] You're a flirtatious girl
- Yeah.
Last time, like I just...
I covered my drug problem real quick
because last time I was a
little scared to bring it up
but then I was like fuck it.
Like, I'm going to be honest about me.
And I'm just going to tell the truth
because it's just like I
have nothing to be ashamed of
because I'm trying to
overcome my problems.
- [Mark] Honesty is powerful
- And there's nothing wrong with that.
- [Mark] Being honest,
I think is the key to
overcoming your things.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I think Patrick, the crack addict
that I've done a couple of interviews with
he's laying it all out.
Everyone loves him
because he's like the most
honest person on my channel.
And there's...it makes you very likable.
- Yeah, Yeah.
I've had a few people,
like after my interview
they've been like, oh, like I heard it.
And I was like, I really liked it.
And I was like, oh, thank you.
It was...I was really nervous to do it
because I thought people
were going to judge me.
But then they were like,
wow, you were like honest.
And that shit was deep.
- [Mark] Well, the key to being
judged harshly or positively
is I think how honest somebody
is when they come in here.
If you're honest and just
lay it all out as Patrick did
I mean, the comments on his
video are unanimously positive.
- Patrick's was really good.
- [Mark] Yeah, he's the best.
- Yeah, I watched the whole
thing and I was like...
I was really relating when he was like,
it's frustrating that my drug addiction
is like my biggest flaw in life.
You know?
Like I could tell that
he was like a smart guy
and society, like he seen his,
like an over round all American guy
but he just has an addiction problem.
I really feel like it's like
a gene thing with some people.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I can really relate to him
- [Mark] Yeah, It's complicated
cause it's genetics.
It's also the trauma you
go through as a child.
- Right.
- [Mark] It's your circumstances,
sometimes you're broke
and you just need to survive somehow.
And then you end up
doing this kind of work
and that requires maybe you ended up
playing around with these
drugs and then you get addicted
and there's so many
different ways this can go.
How is karma work into your life?
- Karma...
- [Mark] Karma is a good
question for all these-
- Yeah, I, like I said, I
was watching some earlier
and you were like, you
sleep with all these guys.
And I feel like that is on them.
Like if you know you have a wife at home
and you're coming out-
- [Mark] But honestly it's on both of you.
- I mean-
- [Mark] You can't just say it's all him.
- I mean, yeah.
I mean, it is on me
because I'm using vanity.
- [Mark] It takes two to tango.
- So I guess, but...
I mean, I would never hurt a fly.
Like I'm not a sinister person.
I'm not doing this to be sinister.
- [Mark] You're just trying to survive.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] But if-
- But I mean, you know, in God's eyes
he's probably like, come on bitch.
You know what's going on.
- [Mark] But I'm not religious
but what God would say
is that he wants you to
do better for yourself
do something where you're
loving yourself more.
And this is probably is not the most self-
- Yeah, I think I'd rather
be like, something more nicer
like a model or something
chic, but it is what it is.
You know, I'll work my
way up there through time.
- [Mark] Sometimes if you treat yourself
as if you were somebody that
you really respect a lot
and you can pick whoever that is a hero
or somebody in your imagination
or God or whoever, Jesus, whatever.
If you imagine yourself
as being that person
and treat yourself that way
then you're treating yourself
with the utmost respect
and you're doing all the
right things for yourself.
And all of a sudden,
everything kind of falls
into place beautifully
because you're not cutting corners.
You're not just like cheating this night
or this guy or this, whatever,
just so you can make some
bucks to feed yourself
that you're treating yourself
as if you truly respect yourself.
And then all of a sudden this type of work
wouldn't really fit into that
because you would never
want your grandmother.
Let's say your grandmother,
you wouldn't want your grandmother
to do this kind of work.
- I wouldn't.
I wouldn't even like want
my friends to do this.
- [Mark] That's what I'm saying.
So you treat yourself
as if you are your
grandmother at 20 years old
or one of your friends
or somebody that you really care about.
- Yeah, but that's some deep shit.
- [Mark] Life is deep.
You can't pretend it's not.
A lot of people don't
like to take it seriously.
And that's how they get into trouble.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] They think they can just like,
not look at that stuff
and then it creeps up
and next thing you know,
you're in a jam.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you're smart
enough to figure this out.
- I know.
- [Mark] You're a smart girl.
(she laughs)
But I'm not judging I think what you're...
you're doing it the right way
and you're making money and that's great.
And you don't look like you're in trouble.
- I'm definitely not in trouble.
- [Mark] You're not getting beaten up.
- Definitely not.
No bruises around here.
- [Mark] You haven't had
any bad experiences, right?
- Not yet.
Not since I've seen you
just those two stories
- [Mark] Yeah, you told me before
- And since then-
- [Mark] It does happen though?
- Yeah, it does happen.
It happens all the time.
All the time.
- [Mark] Talked to your family?
- I haven't really been
talking to my family as much.
My sister, me and her are having...
we're having some disagreements.
Because she wants to enter the game
and I try to give her advice
on how to do it the correct way.
And she just doesn't really
want to listen to me.
So I just feel like,
then just don't do it.
If you don't want to do it the right way.
It's like, I'm your little sister,
but when it comes to this,
like you need to take
heed of what I'm saying.
So we're kind of arguing with that.
And then with my dad,
he... I feel like he's acting
really weird towards me
cause he's not my real
dad he's my adoptive dad
and he's just acting a little strange.
- [Mark] But any dad
or stepdad or whatever
is not going to be pleased
with the situation that you're in.
- Well he's actually like,
I'll send him pictures
and he'll be like, you look gorgeous.
And just, he'll just
say really weird things.
So I haven't really been
texting him that much
because I don't know if
I said in my last video
he was like a little
abusive during my childhood.
And I kind of just got an eye-opener
from a close friend that
he is just on weird shit.
So I was like, okay, let
me just kind of back away.
Cause I was kinda trying to
create a relationship with him.
Like he was my dad, but he's really not
because of what he did
to me when I was a child.
- [Mark] What'd he do when
you were young, if I can ask?
- He just used to like stripped me naked.
And just wet me like all the time.
And when I was like 11, 12.
So when I sent him pictures now
and he's like, you're gorgeous.
And all of this, it's like kind of awkward
because you know he just notices things
that fathers shouldn't notice.
Like he asked me if I
was pregnant one time
and I just feel like when I send him stuff
he just like looks at it
in a way that he shouldn't
be looking at it.
- [Mark] You can sense them.
- Yeah.
I feel like he's just being weird.
- [Mark] Do you think maybe
you're addicted to this lifestyle?
I know you've only been
doing it a year or so.
- No, I don't think... I mean yes and no.
Yeah.
(both laugh)
- [Mark] Yes and no means yes.
Yeah, I think it's gotta be very addicting
because like any other job has got to be-
- I mean, I couldn't be a square.
I could never be a square ever, like ever.
I don't think I could ever be a square.
- [Mark] And once you've done this
it's going to be hard to go back to-
- It's hard.
I mean, I could never be with like a man
who is just not...
Like if you have like trick tendencies
I can't be with you period, point blank.
And if you can't accept that,
I'm gonna go to a grocery store
and I might meet a nice man.
Then I can't be with you.
You know?
- [Mark] So he's supposed to accept
that you've had this
past but you can't accept
that he might've had a similar one.
- I mean,
(Royalty laughs)
That's evil the way did she put it?
- [Mark] It's not evil.
It's just the fact, you're
saying he can't do anything wrong
- I mean, he's never going to
be able to really accept me
because he's always gonna look at me
like, I'm just like, oh
yeah, my wife used to be...
He's always going to feel
like he saved or something
because I've met guys who were like,
oh yeah, my wife used to be a prostitute.
And it's just like, they
feel like they saved her.
And it's some type of way.
And I don't-
- [Mark] I think it's human nature
to kind of wanna do that for people.
I think it's human nature to
wanna save damsels in distress.
- Off course, off course.
- [Mark] Especially when
they're particularly attractive.
I find the comments on
the attractive girls
get 10 times, a hundred times more
people that want to help them.
- Definitely, I mean, I can relate.
I can relate.
- [Mark] So how many years you
think you'll be doing this?
- Just like a couple more.
I honestly, if it doesn't, I
mean, I know it'll work out
it'll work out.
I'm going to get a few things out of this
but,
I would just stop cold turkey
if I was like, getting
like pressing that 30 line,
even like 26 line.
Cause that's a little-
- [Mark] In terms of age?
- Yeah, that's pushing it.
It's pushing it.
That's just me.
That's just my thinking.
I feel like if you're 25 and older,
you should not be an escort
or prostitute or any type of-
- [Mark] All right, Royalty.
Well, thank you so much for
sharing your story again.
Come on in again
- Thank you for having me
- [Mark] I wish you the best of luck.
Be careful in Vegas.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] I hope you save lots of money.
- [Mark] And I hope you get out one day.
- Thank you so much.
- [Mark] All right girl, thank you.
- Okay.